JavaScript also has support for numbers,
and just like in Python they can be whole numbers.
They can have decimal fractional parts,
or they can be negative.
I like all of those, but all of these examples here in blue at the bottom,
1.2.3.4, that has too many decimal points.
This is not a number written using digits.
This is not a number at all, although I may have its number.
That would totally work.
Now that we have an intuition for what numbers look like in JavaScript,
there's a quiz.
I'd like you to define t_number that matches the examples in red
but does not match the examples in blue,
but normally the value of a token is a string.
I want you to convert it to a float before returning.